well he's more than basketball he's
brought in city of Los Angeles together
I mean it is really really horrible what
happened I mean he was only 41 years old
he has a you know I heard a 13 year old
daughter on board and there were two
accounts the first account said that
there were only six people now I found
out there were nine people on the plane
also looked through a telephoto lens
that one of my friends here from let me
look through and I could see there were
three people up there I saw a body bag
and I also saw the tail of the
helicopter it was red and I saw that and
when I first got here there was maybe 15
people here and I saw the officers not
even arriving yet I saw just one just
one that had come down the street then
later in the day I happen to see that
all the fire engines and the paramedics
and then the reporters come but it was
pretty sparse here in the beginning and
pretty sad
Brian applause
to come out and show that he meant
everything to me it's a sad day very
very sad when I first came here there
was the streets were still open there
was not this many fans you could say
there was just a few news but now it's
just a lot of people I see they're
coming alive but it was I was here like
one of the first ones the smoke was
bigger the smoke was way bigger like you
were able to see it like smiles back
like maybe two three miles back I was
able to say when I was driving when I
was going down find out it was nine
instead of five and then I found that it
was Gianna that was on there
I followed her you know on Instagram and
loved her passion for the basketball
like she was following her dad's
footsteps it was something that we had
to look forward to in her you know in
Kobe's passion for basketball that was
his little mini-me and now to know that
she's gone - I feel so far for the
Bryant's and Vanessa and her four other
daughters it's to society sad day
I had to come here and just be around
all this you know morning together Laker
family
my buddy text me the TMZ shot and shock
just like complete shock like I thought
it was a joke you know you go on
internet and trying to see if this is
just a hoax and unfortunately it wasn't
well he's more than basketball I mean
he's brought in city of Los Angeles
together as you can see today here at
Staples Center at this moment there's
hundreds of Laker fans you know honoring
him and as as a man I mean he was a
family person he brought his wife and
daughters ahead of everything after
basketball I mean he won an Oscar he
he's expanded his enterprise Kobe knee
with Mama Sports Academy
I mean it's countless of things he's
done Nike all these new generation
players if you see on their feet you see
a lot of people wearing Jordans but you
also see a lot of people wearing Kobe
shoes too so that's the impact I think
he's had on the game of basketball in
general in the world
Kobe Delta's we live in a limitless
world in terms of her potential and are
born with our family everything we owed
Kobe Kobe Bryant long live his memory
you